let's continue on with our study of
rotation of if I guess functions around
the X and we'll soon see the y axis as
well so let's let's do a slightly harder
example than what we've been doing but I
think it might be obvious how to
approach it so there's my y axis
there's my x axis and in a couple of I
think it was two problems ago we we
figured out if we had the function y is
equal to square root of x let me try to
draw it so this is y equals square root
of x if we were to rotate rotate that
around the x axis what the volume would
be between two points let's say you know
zero and some other point now let's just
pick an arbitrary point one and I think
you know how to do that at this point
now let's make it a slightly more
difficult problem let's say I were to
also draw the function y is equal to x
squared so that looks and if this is one
they both meet at one right because the
square root of 1 is 1 and 1 squared is 1
so that would look something like this
something like that they should be
actually symmetric around y equals x but
anyway so say y equals x squared looks
looks like that so my question now is
what is the volume if I were to take
this figure and rotate it around so what
do I mean so this area here if I were to
rotate that about the x axis
what would the volume be so now this is
really the what we did just with the
square root of x we had like a solid cup
right it would look something like this
it would be like a cup and it was solid
and we were just trying to figure out
the volume of it hopefully hopefully
that makes sense to you now it's going
to be kind of a hollowed-out cup right
because we have this inside function and
so the inside of the cup is going to be
empty hopefully that makes a little
sense remember just you're just taking
this and then you're rotating it around
the x axis well the way to think about
it especially if you're having trouble
visualizing actually that the solution
might help you visualize it the volume
of this figure which I'm having trouble
drawing
it will be the volume formed by the
outside rotation right of say this you
know y equals square root of x let me do
that in the yellow square root of X
it'll be the volume formed when that is
rotated around and the whole solid
volume minus the volume when minus this
volume minus so if we took if we took
the y equals x squared right y equals x
squared would look something like that
and if you rotated it around the axis
and draw it'll look something like that
and if you ever been to Morocco but they
have these tagine plates that look at
the tops look a lot like that what you
probably have well anyway it would look
something like that so if we subtract
out this this volume when it's rotated
around from the volume of y equals
square root of x when that rotator will
get this figure that we're trying to
figure out this area when it's rotating
around and that should be intuitive for
you hopefully because when we just did
area under the curve that's how we would
figure out the area of this green area
we would figure out the area under
square root of x and we'd subtract out
the area under y equals x squared that's
y equals x squared this time we're going
to say the volume of the revolution of y
equals square root of x minus the volume
of the revolution of y equals x squared
so let's let's do the problem all right
so the total volume a total volume let
me do a good color looks good the total
total volume is going to be equal to the
volume for we rotate y equals square
root of x around the x-axis and I said
from 0 to 1 and that's because I picked
where they enter they meet sometimes in
a book or on an example to say oh you
know the area between y equals x squared
and y equals square of X we're going to
rotate that around and you have to
figure out well they intersect it at 1
and you could just set the equations
equal to each other to figure that
we're going from zero to one because
they also intersect at zero right
0 squared is the same thing as square
root of zero going from zero to one and
so what's the volume of the larger or I
guess the y equals square root of x
rotate it around
I always forget the formula so I always
redraw a disk so if that's the radius of
my disk the disk is going to come around
like that so we know that the radius is
the function right of the disk and
that's of course the DX is the the depth
of the disk so the radius is a function
which for the outside one is square root
of x square root of X and we know area
of this disk is PI R squared so we
square the radius take a PI outside and
then we multiply that times the width so
that's where we get our DX and of course
we sum them all up and that's where we
get the integral and then I'm going to
I'm going to do it as two separate
integrals some people will put them both
within the same integral but I really
want to hit the point home that this is
the volume of the kind of outside
surface formed by the outside surface or
the cup minus the volume formed by the
inside function this is going to be
minus PI it's still going to be from 0
to 1 0 don't let those I drew fairly
huge integral signs I don't know why and
what's the inside function it's x
squared right and that's going to be the
radius of its own disks right if that's
the radius that's the disk DX is the
width so it'll be x squared squared
times DX all right so let's see if we
can figure that out so volume equals
let's take the PI's out I think you know
you'll see that that pi is applying to
everything so we can take a PI out and
then Ty times the integral and now we
can merge them back because you know
integrals are additive like that if the
well you'll see what I'm talking about
this integral is the same thing so what
square root of x squared well that's
just X and what's X
squared squared that's X to the fourth
right you multiply the exponents
exponent rules we have a minus sign here
minus X to the fourth times DX make that
pie on the outside that equals let's
keep our pie on the outside we're going
to have to evaluate the antiderivative
at one and zero so what's the
antiderivative of X well it's x squared
over two x squared over two - what's the
antiderivative of X to the fourth what's
X to the fifth over five let's hopefully
second nature to you X to the fifth over
five and we're going to evaluate that at
1 and 0 1 and zero we're going to
subtract them right fundamental theorem
of calculus so that equals I'm going to
switch colors to avoid monotony that
equals pi times let's evaluate it at one
so it's 1/2 minus one-fifth 1/2 minus
one-fifth when you evaluate a zero is
zero minus zero so when you're value
zero you get nothing
and so what's 1/2 minus one-fifth that's
pi times two common denominator of ten
five halves is one half minus two tenths
is one-fifth so this equals this will be
three so we get three PI over 10 that's
the volume formed so it's it's almost
easier to figure out the volume of this
figure than to draw it anyway I think
I'll leave you there this video and in
the next video we're going to start
rotating around the y axis
see you soon